[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport c'est le premier numéro de
cette saison sur TV 78 au programme
aujourd'hui comme toujours des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique s'il vous plaît de cette dream
team on commence à ma droite musique il
est en très grande forme pour cette
grande première de l'année il adore
donner le dernier coup de rang
nécessaire pour remporter un débat il
est notre spécialiste cyclisme et bien
plus encore le capitaine gagne est avec
nous pendant une heure bonsoir Michael
heureux d'être parmi vous heureux de
revenir et de pouvoir refaire une
émission ensemble on est très heureux de
vous avoir à quelques jours en plus des
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste ça commenceront ici au vu le don
de national de 50 ans en Yvelines ça
tombe très bien en effet on va en parler
on continue notre tour de table à gauche
musique vous reconnaissez sa musique il
est journaliste chez TV 78 c'est une
vraie encyclopédie sur le sport Yveline
Wilde est aussi un grand fan du football
italien notre italienne lover Grégory
qu'elle allait est avec nous pendant une
heure
bonjour à tous alors est-ce que c'est un
rêve c'est bien réel on est bien en
plateau on est en plateau
on ne pensait plus retrouver dans cette
saison mais enfin très heureux de
retrouver toute la team pour parler
sport et de sport Yves dinois bien sûr
une nouvelle envolée c'est ça dans dans
cette émission c'est le rendez-vous
habituel rendez-vous tant attendu pour
chaque SOP si on parlait sport mais
effectivement il envolé tout à l'heure
je vous laisserai révéler le thème tout
à l'heure vous voulez lyrics comme
d'habitude avec vous à Grégory on
continue de l'autre côté musique les
fans de ce tal que le compas à George
Clooney il nous vient tout droit des
contrées Versailles c'est un gentleman
toujours super élégant il adore la
bagarre et les mellets gladiateur Pierre
Chevalier du Rugby Club de Versailles
avec nous la bagarre salut les copains
je suis très très ému de revenir surtout
que j'avais loupé quelques petites
quelques petites envolées quelques
petites émissions en fin de saison
dernière sur notre site
limite en léger différé en live mais bon
quand on a pas le choix dans la date on
s'adapte
enfin voici notre dernier chroniqueur
musique c'est notre cerise sur le gâteau
notre flamme olympique notre superstar
notre
superstar notre statut Jean-Mi s'ex
entraîneur de plaisir nous fait
l'honneur de venir ici sur ce plateau
pendant une heure comment allez-vous
Jean à tous bonne soirée
sur un beau bateau on va parler rugby
notamment aujourd'hui
voilà vous êtes venus pour ça oh non pas
que vous pourrez être parmi vous déjà et
puis pour parler de des différents
sujets sportifs du département qui sont
très intéressants ce soir on est très
content en tout cas de vous avoir sur ce
plateau alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission on va parler
d'une championne d'aviron claire
Beauvais livinoise de 23 ans Vich
championne olympique est devenu l'égérie
de la maison de prestige Mauboussin
spécialisé dans les bijoux à
l'accompagnera la marque au minimum
jusqu'au Jeux Olympiques de Paris en
2024 est-ce que c'est un bon coup de
publicité pour l'aviron oui ou non
vous votez oui pour vous il y a du
Jarrier premier à dégainer comme comme
souvent ou partager par contre Jean vous
êtes partagés pourquoi parce que tout le
monde est unanime c'est un bon coup de
pub vous mais moi pas forcément juste
partager tout simplement parce que je la
connais pas déjà et je pense ne pas être
le seul de dans ce cas de figure donc
c'est pour ça que je suis déjà en
partager bien sûr que une fois qu'on va
dire c'est clair mauvais elle n'a rien à
voir avec José
pas les mêmes moustaches
mais sinon il nous faut qu'on va dire
oui c'est clair mauvais
dans l'aviron ok on va l'identifier et
là c'est un plus pour l'aviron mais
sinon moi je viens de regarder la photo
voilà je ne la connaissais pas donc donc
c'est pour ça que je suis légèrement
mitigé sur le fait que ça va
ça va exploser l'avion c'est le problème
de ces sports secondaires qui en effet
ne brille pas et maintenant vous voulez
dire plutôt moi médiatique oui parce que
bien sûr il ramène des médailles et
c'est ça brille du coup mais c'est vrai
que les journalistes et les médias en
parlent n'en parle pas assez tout
simplement le football prend prend de
toute façon beaucoup trop de place
je reçois l'équipe tous les jours et je
je passe 15 pages 15 pages par jour que
je ne que je ne regarde pas donc c'est
bien dommage parce que justement
l'actualité du sport en France ne se
résume pas au foot et donc tous ces tous
ces sports c'est tous ces sportifs
mériteraient que l'on parle beaucoup
plus de donc ben là c'est très bien que
qu'une marque puisse puisse les soutenir
parce que c'est aussi un soutien pour
elle et puis faire passer son image par
par cette par cette par cette sportive
moi je trouve que c'est justement une
très bonne occasion de faire sortir un
petit peu ces sports moins exposés là on
en 30 secondes on a on a rappelé que en
aviron en plus les Français et les
Françaises performent plutôt
sportivement et là qu'une marque
nationale de prestige parce que une
marque de bijouterie donc tout ce qui
brille justement se rapproche de ce qui
a besoin de briller au niveau médiatique
c'est une très bonne chose Mauboussin
est une est une marque de bijouterie
nationale c'est pas forcément la plus la
plus luxueuse qui soit dans ce que dans
ce que l'on propose peut proposer en
France mais c'est une marque qui est
connue c'est une marque qui est qui est
qui est achetée et qui est apprécié je
pense de la plupart des Français et donc
là ne serait-ce que pour cette
exposition c'était
tu es pas médiatique mais dans les
journaux dans les dans les dans les
prises de dans les prises de de parole
graphiques on va dire c'est une bonne
chose et ça va mettre un petit coup de
projecteur sur un sport qui en a besoin
avec une effectivement une athlète qu'on
connaît pas forcément très bien je pense
que les deux les deux entités vont
pouvoir profiter l'une de l'autre la
mauvaise qui est quand même riche
championnat olympique en avion c'est une
marque aussi qui met en avant d'habitude
des personnalités un peu plus connues
l'ajustement bah ça va mettre un petit
coup de projecteur sur claire Bover
parce que vous l'avez rappelé elle est
vice-championne olympique l'aviron ça a
été dit et une discipline pourvoyeuse de
médailles pour pour l'équipe de France
en général donc ça va la mettre en avant
et c'est aussi dans cette stratégie qui
va monter petit à petit en puissance il
y a des Jeux Olympiques en 2024 en
France et forcément bah il faut
connaître nos athlètes il faut connaître
les disciplines même celles qui sont
moins médiatiques qu'on ressent un peu
du placard à chaque olympiade et je
pense que c'est aussi important dans
cette stratégie que tous les acteurs que
ce soit les institutionnels mais aussi
les entreprises et aussi les groupes
puissent tirer dans le même sens pour
mettre en avant cette olympiade qu'on
connaîtra peut-être qu'une fois dans
notre vie en France donc c'est important
de mettre en avant l'aviron a été
médiatisée là cet été avec les jeux
européens et
pas jouer européen d'ailleurs c'était
les championnats d'Europe et multi
multidisciplinaire et c'est vrai que
moi j'ai quand j'ai vu les épreuves
beaucoup de enfin les les intervenants
disaient qu'en effet là il y avait un
décrit pas un déclic mais une marge de
progression qui était qui était en cours
sur l'aviron français donc les résultats
étaient déjà bons moi j'attends de très
belles de très belles choses sur sur
Paris 2024 elle a une médaille d'argent
d'ailleurs sur ses championnats d'Europe
claire Beauvais alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler rugby et de la fédérale 2 quelle
sera la meilleure équipe Evinoise entre
eux plaisir et Versailles nous parlons
également de golf l'Open de France s'est
déroulé fin septembre à 50 ans en
Yvelines mais avant de parler de ces
thématiques on va parler football
[Musique]
dans cette page football on va parler du
FC Versailles vous le savez le promu
versaillais a d'énormes ambitions avec
notamment un gros recrutement et pour
l'instant ça ne se passe pas trop mal
pour les joueurs de la cité royale dans
le championnat de National les versets
sont pour l'instant à la 8e place du
classement avec un bilan de 3 victoires
3000 et 2 défaites point positif ils ne
sont qu'à trois points du premier
Dunkerque pour l'instant ils sont
toujours bien placés pour monter en
Ligue 2 en fin de saison mais ce n'est
pas forcément l'objectif affiché du club
la question sur cette thématique selon
vous est-ce que c'est un bon début de
saison pour le promu Versailles oui non
vous êtes d'accord sujet suivant
je me souviens ce qu'on a dit en fin de
saison
au mois de juillet sur les dernières
émissions qu'on espérait que Versailles
puisse puisse se maintenir dans cette
excité vraiment le premier objectif à
mettre en place surtout avec la perte
des effectifs qui qui avait c'était on
pensait que ça allait être compliqué et
en effet ben bonne surprise après après
8 journées donc pas parce que on a la
chance de commencer la saison un peu
tard cette année pas après deux trois
matchs ben c'est vrai que on s'aperçoit
que bah ils sont dans le coup et tant
mieux ça veut dire que les recrutements
ont été bons le message du coach
continue de passer c'est pas c'est pas
négligeable et donc bah que le projet
que le projet est solide donc tant mieux
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui tous les feux
sont au vert et
voilà on va je vais rester sur un le
discours que j'avais en fin de conserver
cette cette place en National pour
pouvoir passer à l'étape supérieure un
peu plus tard et ne pas vouloir gravir
des étapes trop vite donc pour vous
c'est pas une bonne idée de monter dès
cette saison je pense que ce serait une
fois mettre
après on peut pas savoir les moyens qui
sont mis en place est-ce que ce qu'ils
auraient la possibilité mais je pense
que là on va faire une saison et refaire
une saison à la prochaine en National ça
serait bien Jean qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
alors moi je suis légèrement vous allez
dire je suis mitigé encore j'ai dit oui
parce que oui c'est un bon départ après
on est objectif on dit ils sont juste à
trois points du premier mais ils sont
aussi à deux points du dernier non
on a vu la première partie
de ce tableau la précision ils sont à
ils sont à 3 points de la 13e place et
si la régulation et qui est relégation
cette saison nationale
ça fait trois points au-dessus mais
trois points en dessous ils sont au
milieu c'est un bon départ moi je dirais
moi je dirais quand même un coup de
chapeau Youssef chibi le rentrer
de faire performer son équipe il y a eu
un gros changement on l'avait dit
énormément énormément de de recrues de
départ et d'arrivée donc faire prendre
la mayonnaise c'est pas facile on le
sait dans l'espoir collectif donc moi je
dis coup de chapeau déjà à l'entraîneur
ensuite la saison est longue mais il
vaut mieux démarrer avec un état 3
points en regardant devant et on se dit
on est juste à côté que démarrer au fond
et dire on va ramer donc oui c'est
positif mais faut pas s'emballer la
saison est longue il faut continuer à
travailler sérieusement continuez à y
mettre les ingrédients qui à mon avis
sur les bons peut-être certainement
l'enthousiasme qui fait de cette équipe
depuis leur parcours en Coupe de France
je crois qu'ils ont gardé cette
dynamique pas les joueurs puisque c'est
plus les mêmes pour la plupart mais au
moins le staff au moins l'équipe
dirigeante certainement et ça ça
continue à se à se concrétiser sur le
terrain donc c'est tout bonus pour moi
un chevalier ce sont nos voisins et nos
haies nos amis nos amis à Versailles
centre et à Porchefontaine donc on se on
discute on discute pas mal et on et
justement et puis on s'inspire on
s'inspire un petit peu de leur de leur
trajet je vais pas revenir sur la saison
dernière et sur cette épopée en Coupe de
France et sur la montée dont on a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup parlé juste parler en
complément de ce qu'on dit il y a des
gens de du contexte de début de saison
qui qui selon contre toute attente a été
quand même un peu compliqué pour une
équipe de sport donc on a parlé surtout
d'extra sportif aussi en début en début
de saison et là aller voir à cette
position là en tant que promu et on en
parlera un peu plus tard être promu
c'est un statut et ça doit ça doit
s'assumer en gros
au foot comme au rugby mais au football
ils ont connu quand même donc cette
histoire cette histoire de stade où
est-ce qu'il où est-ce qu'il reçoive les
équipes les équipes en championnat donc
atterrissage à Jean-Bouin sur le sur le
terrain du Stade Français Paris
finalement ça ça se met ça se met quand
même bien en place
ça sonne un peu creux national dans un
dans un stade de plus de 20 000 mais
mais c'est un bel écran un bel écrin
pour le pour le bijou royal de du FCV et
puis il y a eu l'extrait sportif aussi
Jean tu le rappeler tu auras tu
rappelles pas tout ce qui a concerné
Youssef chibi en début de saison ces
petites histoires judiciaires qui
tombent comme un cheveu sur la soupe et
qui perturbe peut-être Grégory
il a été auditionné il y a une enquête
qui a été ouverte parce que Youssef
chibi et soupçonné d'atteinte à
l'intimité de la vie privée et
d'enregistrement aussi de d'image pedo
pornographique pardon sur un sur un
mineur de 15 ans il aurait dissimulé des
caméras c'est en tout cas ce qui a été
révélé par nos confrères du Parisien
pour l'instant l'affaire reste sans
suite il faut dire que dans cette
affaire il y a une présomption
d'innocence il n'a pas été mis en examen
à ce jour et c'est vrai que comme le
disait juste par rapport à ce dossier
donc polémique voilà et c'est pas c'est
pas les meilleurs conditions pour un
entraîneur de d'assumer le statut de
promu et de mon temps pour démarrer que
Youssef chibi entraîne à ce niveau là
donc c'était pas c'était pas les
meilleures conditions donc les voir à ce
niveau là
en considérant un recrutement
recrutement intéressant effectivement
c'est déjà une bonne chose mais comme
vous l'avez tous rappelé la saison est
longue tenons bon au moins en National
et puis on verra on verra on verra pour
la suite
qu'ils ont joué ils ont quand même joué
aussi les équipes
donc on peut aussi être un championnat
de très serré pour l'instant c'est ce
que j'en disais sur les points c'est
très serré mais ça n'empêche qu'ils ont
quand même joué les équipes du du haut
de classement peut-être que dans les
prochaines prochaines semaines en jouant
ceux qui ont eu un peu plus de mal à
démarrer ça peut être un peu plus facile
aussi et marquer plus de facilité à
prendre des points moi je pense qu'on
peut on pourra peut-être regarder où
est-ce qu'ils en sont dans un mois un
mois et demi et de toute façon on le
fera avec avec grande grande attention
Grégory qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous bah excellent début de saison je
dis excellent parce que on parle quand
même d'un alors oui ils sont mieux de
tableaux ils sont à mi-chemin entre une
première place et aussi une place de
relégab parce qu'ils sont qu'à trois
points de cette 13e place qui est
relégable on rappelle que dans le
championnat national il y a 6 décembre à
la fin de la saison pour le championnat
national de seulement deux montées pour
le championnat de Ligue 2 la Ligue 2
c'est un objectif assumé par les
Versailles mais je pense que cette
saison il faut jouer le maintien et ça a
été rappelé alors tous les bons
arguments ont été donnés mais ce que je
pourrais dire c'est que dans l'effectif
qui a été largement renouvelé il y a
quand même une quinzaine de joueurs
nouveau qui sont arrivés dans cet
effectif bah il y a des joueurs qui se
sont bien intégrés je me suis adressé la
liste parce que je les avais observés
lors des matchs en visio chez j'ai même
pu aller les voir aussi du côté du stade
Jean-Bouin
et Sébastien Raynaud le gardien qui a
été décisif depuis le début de la saison
il a été l'auteur de nombreux arrêts
mais je peux parler aussi de Loïc
d'amour Thibault Jacques aussi qui a
marqué marqué deux buts et à côté de ça
bah des joueurs versaillais qui se sont
maintenus au sein du club je pense à
Diego Michel a capeo Silva qui cette
année à mon avis c'est deux joueurs il
faut les surveiller ils vont éclore un
certain niveau et je pense qu'on va
parler d'eux dans les dans les saisons à
venir et capitaux aussi en attaque qui a
été l'auteur de buts j'ai trouvé
finalement la saison dernière qui ont
emmené Versailles en demi-finale de
Coupe de France sur lequel Youssef Chili
aussi mise beaucoup c'est l'attaquant
titulaire de cette sélection
marseillaise de cette formation
versaillesse et moi je trouve qu'il a un
vrai poids sur les défenses enfin c'est
vraiment un attaquant de grand talent
aussi et donc tous les voyants sont
ouverts maintenant on va voir ce qu'il
en est il y a quand même aussi de
grosses recrues des recrues un peu
phares qui sont arrivés il y a
jeremenland je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en parler Aix international
néerlandais qui a quand même quatre
matchs de Coupe du monde à son actif il
a joué que quelques minutes avec les
Versailles il est encore blessé donc on
en attente aussi de de l'apport de de
parler justement de de
terminer juste citer Fabien Lemoine
Fabien Lemoine autre recrue phare
également de Ligue 1 et qui lui c'est
très bien intégré et je trouve qu'il a
toute sa place pour le moment aussi dans
cet effectif Versailles il a été
l'auteur de bonnes prestations justement
on vous parler de lance du coup le
joueur hollandais vous l'avez dit à
Grégory 75 matchs européens quatre
matchs je coupe du monde vous le voyez
sur sur ces images bon au niveau
physique apparemment il y a encore du
boulot il a joué que une vingtaine de
minutes c'est ça il a joué une vingtaine
de minutes c'était face à
Bourg-en-Bresse victoire de à zéro des
Versailles il était rentré en fin de
match mais il est sorti sur blessure et
il avait laissé son équipe à 9 contre
expulsions et depuis on l'a plus vu il
était arrivé alors d'après les
informations qui filtrent dans la presse
avec quelques kilos en trop une
quinzaine de kilos en trop il n'a pas
encore la forme espérée mais dit-on
aussi au sein de l'effectif c'est aussi
Youssef chibi kildi c'est un jour qui
s'est très bien intégré et qui est très
apprécié au sein du groupe voilà je vois
très apprécié au sein du groupe une
bonne pioche selon vous il y a une vue
arrière Solens on sera quand il aura
récupéré de blessure et quand il aura
fait un match complet tout simplement
mais ça peut simplement de la muscu
peut-être mais bon quand même
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre j'ai du mal
on a pas tous les éléments à comprendre
les sportifs qui pourraient même de au
niveau qui pourra ne serait-ce que
prendre 10 kg pendant l'hiver je trouve
ça un peu hallucinant mais après euh
bon ça va nous dit que non apparemment
c'est pas possible toujours voilà et
donc euh
et donc ouais juste bah oui on verra
quand il aura fait ses ses proches tout
simplement et qui pourra et par contre
oui ça laisse espérer une montée de de
niveau encore plus rajouter à des matchs
un peu un peu peut-être plus facile dans
quelques temps ça peut vraiment être
quelque chose de sympa chez les plus
grands ça me fait ça me fait penser à
Boateng à Lyon qui est en gros les des
recrues alors encore un Néerlandais mais
des recrues qui sont sur le papier
extrêmement rentables parce que c'est
allemand
Jérôme Boateng ah c'est pas Willi alors
bon
et qui finalement sont
s'avère pas forcément être la bonne
pioche donc vous parliez ça va dépendre
surtout de son de son de sa remise en
forme remise en forme le mental
l'expérience a priori ça il l'a mais à
cet âge-là on est bien placé pour le
pour le dire c'est la récup est plus
difficile et tant qu'on a pas un
physique impeccable il va le trait il va
traîner sa caravane là pendant toute la
saison et en plus il sort d'une saison
il a quasiment pas joué avec le Besiktas
donc club turc donc c'est vrai qu'il
arrive vraiment dans une forme on dit
hors-forme là il est complètement en
forme faut qu'il se remette en place
mais ça peut durer plusieurs mois c'est
peut-être un mal pour un bien finalement
cette blessure qui va lui permettre de
se
ré-atlétiser genre qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous de Delance vous avez pas
entendu sur sur cette question non mais
tout est carrément été dit autour de la
table simplement il est certain que ça
m'efforme et sa prise de poids
n'est pas étrangère à sa blessure
puisque forcément avec 15 kg de plus il
va d'ailleurs si il les perd pas à 34
ans il faudra que se blesser et ce sera
une mauvaise purge pour pour Versailles
par contre s'il arrive vraiment à voir
le mental pour perdre ses 15 kg vu la
carte visite de killa je pense que c'est
vraiment un plus pour pour l'équipe et
pour les ambitions que Versailles peut
avoir une dernière question peut-être
sur Versailles à quel moment pourra dire
que le FC Versailles est un prétendant
sérieux pour une montée quand tu vas
monter
dans deux ans
des moyens qui ont été mis sur la table
on a parlé des recrues un peu Farid
aussi Rachid Alioui qui est
international marocain qui est arrivé
donc il y a des moyens qui sont mis des
internationaux en tout cas sont présents
dans les pays sur sur la table on va
voir si il en est au milieu de saison
est un candidat à la montée peut-être
quand ils auront construit le stade qui
leur permettra de jouer à Versailles ça
c'est ça c'est notre
une autre question
normalement si tout va bien en tout cas
on suivra avec attention les
performances du FC Versailles dans les
prochaines semaines les hommes de Yosef
chibi joueront le mercredi 12 octobre
contre Le Mans à domicile au stade
Jean-Bouin donc on va maintenant passer
à notre envolée du jour avec vous
Grégory elle a énormément manqué au
téléspectateurs de TV 78 pendant l'été
c'est à vous de quoi allez-vous nous
parler aujourd'hui Grégory d'un derby
pour le plus grand plaisir des Yvelines
à d'un côté le
plaisir Rugby Club ça ne s'invente pas
et de l'autre le Rugby Club de
Versailles et cette saison les deux
équipes du département s'affrontent en
fédéral 2 le cinquième échelon national
le premier round c'est disputer le 25
septembre dernier une première depuis
2011 date de la dernière confrontation
entre les deux équipes c'était un au
stade Robert Barran qui était plein à
plaisir une tribune garnie tout comme le
bord terrain avec des supporters qui se
connaissent bien dans le public c'était
bon enfant du chambrage comme on l'aime
et ça fait partie du jeu il faut le dire
mais après des saisons compliquées on
est vraiment heureux quand même faut le
dire de retrouver ce genre d'ambiance
dans les stades d'ailleurs si vous
voulez voir revoir le match le replay
disponible sur la page Facebook de TV 78
commentée par lymphatigable Nicolas
dandry c'était l'instant autopromo
faites bien je fais bien alors sur le
terrain les plaisirs étaient
ultra dominateurs ils ont pris largement
le dessus sur les Versaillais hauteur de
nombreuses erreurs le score 44 à 7 c'est
le score final pour plaisir on
s'attendait il faut le dire aussi à une
telle différence de niveau plaisir c'est
un habitué de la fédérale 2 le club
fréquente la division depuis quelques
années déjà il y a même frôlé la
qualification pour les phases finales la
saison dernière il y a aussi de grandes
ambitions dit-on atteints pourquoi pas
la Pro D2 d'ici 2032 c'est ce que j'ai
vu aussi passer dans la presse alors
pour cet exercice le PRC 4e pour le
moment avec deux victoires et une
défaite veut terminer dans les six
premières places si le jaune de phase
finale les moyens ont été mis sur la
table avec les nombreux renforts arrivés
cet été on écoute le coach Sébastien
rocali
objectif c'est d'être dans les six
premiers de jouer la qualification et
après on prendra tout ce qui viendra
donc voilà on va prendre tous les matchs
pour les gagner très clairement on a on
a vécu notamment l'année dernière une
année très difficile en terme d'effectif
on a réussi à la tenir malgré tout on a
eu quand même de l'aristide de pas avoir
trop de blessures ça aurait pu être
beaucoup plus compliqué mais bon là
cette année on est on est vraiment sur
du quantitatif et du qualitatif
intéressant donc voilà tant que ça
restera dans cet état d'esprit je pense
qu'on pourra continuer à proposer des
belles choses sur un terrain
pour Versailles en revanche club
centenaire cette saison est un des
chapitres les plus excitants de son
histoire je cite nos confrères du Midi
Olympique qui a consacré un article à
l'équipe versaillesse effectivement au
terme d'un exercice de 1021 2022
exceptionnel une ultime double
confrontation à suspense contre
Vincennes le RCV a obtenu sa première
montée en Fédérale 2 il y a également de
l'ambition pour la jeune direction en
place depuis 5 ans mais cette saison
sera surtout celle de l'apprentissage
des débuts surprises avec un succès à
Orsay une courte défaite de trois points
à domicile contre Saint-Malo avant la
lourde déconvenue contre le plaisir
Versailles pour le moment à dixième elle
va jouer le maintien
ouais clairement c'est le maintien après
on va essayer de prendre les matchs
après les matchs d'aller prendre des
points là où on peut de gagner un
maximum à domicile et puis et puis on
fera les comptes à la fin mais c'est
clairement le maintien il y a clairement
un niveau d'écart enfin il y a une
fédérale d'écart entre nos deux équipes
aujourd'hui donc on apprend c'est sûr il
va falloir qu'on se bouge le cul et
qu'on passe à l'entraînement parce que
sinon on va en prendre 30 à chaque
dimanche quoi deux destinés donc
différentes que l'on va suivre avec
attention cette saison et je ne sais pas
pour vous mais j'ai déjà devoir le match
retour ce sera le 22 janvier 2023 du
côté du stade de Porchefontaine on a
hâte d'y être déjà Grégory alors la
question sur cette thématique tout
simplement votre avis sur cette
magnifique encore une nouvelle fois
envolée de Grégory
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on va
peut-être donner la parole déjà à vous
yanniste de rugby ouais ben non on adore
on adore cette chanson
oui
maintenant voilà je pense que
le beau la plus belle saison serait que
plaisir monte enfin dans la division
supérieure et que Versailles puisse ce
maintenir en fédéral 2 voilà et là on
aurait on aurait je pense atteint les
objectifs pour le département
Jean qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
c'est la sixième division Grégory c'est
la 6e division depuis cette année et
national
merci
il faut préciser justement
depuis cette année
Jean
sur la volée ou sur les deux mon général
la volée
ce duel on va dire à distance entre
Versailles et plaisir qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez on va en parler quand même
cette saison forcément il y a deux clubs
qui sont à ce niveau là on va faire et
je pense que la logique a été respectée
Versailles est à la place de plaisir il
y a 4-5 saisons rappelez-vous plaisir
quand ils sont montés en Fédérale 2 je
sais de quoi je parle puisque j'étais
l'entraîneur qui a fait monter donc les
premiers temps ils ont joué le maintien
ils ont failli même deux reprises les
deux premières saisons des redescendre
et ils se sont maintenus
jusqu'à voilà jusqu'à vraiment mais être
maintenant bien assis à ce niveau là et
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure très
justement ils ont même raté de peu la
qualification avec l'an dernier la
victoire à domicile de l'ogre de la
poule qui était Nantes et qui était qui
était une victoire fabuleuse pour le
club et qui a montré qu'ils étaient
vraiment une équipe de fédéral 2 sur
laquelle il fallait compter donc
aujourd'hui moi ça me surprend
absolument pas Versailles est un
apprentissage à ce niveau là
l'exploit de d'Orsay exploit d'Orsay
quand on connaît un petit peu il a
explicable puisque là il y avait c'était
plus un petit peu une rivalité avec des
joueurs d'Orsay qui avait quitté le club
pour aller pour signer à Versailles donc
il y avait un petit peu de rivalité
entre les joueurs sur ce match là ça
s'est joué serré et Versailles a gagné
la motivation était peut-être pas la
même c'est dommage il devrait avoir
cette motivation tous les dimanches
parce qu'ils sont capables quand même
logistiquement de fournir un match de ce
niveau là puisque Orsay quand même est
une équipe aussi habituée de la fédérale
2 donc la déconvenue on va dire que
c'est un on va dire allez c'est parce
qu'il y avait peut-être cet enjeu autour
de ce match sur qui va être l'équipe
phare du 78 et ça les a peut-être
justement un petit peu tétanisé les
joueurs de Versailles ils sont en plein
apprentissage pour l'instant il y a rien
à dire
ils rendent des des feuilles de match
qui sont bien ils perdent bêtement pour
moi chez eux quand on sait Malo donc
voilà il y a pas pérenna demain
continuons l'apprentissage et je pense
que ça pourra ça pourra le faire pour
cette saison et le maintien sera rassuré
pas entendu en plateau et c'est vrai que
le mot apprentissage c'est le mot
utilisé par Damien berstraet qu'on a
entendu joueur de Versailles c'est
vraiment cette philosophie là qui est
mise en avant du côté du RCV cette
saison Pierre Chevalier apprentissage
de l'intérieur on ne peut que confirmer
ces dires sur l'envolée de Greg je le
remercie de ne pas avoir tapé trop fort
et de ne pas avoir rappelé le score ça
c'est déjà c'est très irrégulier
exactement je suis sélectivement sourd
dans ces cas-là donc merci de merci
d'avoir été élégant dans dans la dans la
traduction de de ce résultat et de ce
match ce début de saison il est
effectivement à l'image de ce que l'on
imaginait en accédant pour la première
fois de notre histoire à la fédérale 2
c'est-à-dire que on se frotte à des
clubs qui sont pour la plupart à trois
exceptions près en Fédérale 2 depuis
quelques années c'est le cas de plaisir
c'est le cas du Havre par exemple c'est
le cas de du rôle près de Rennes c'est
le cas de Ris-Orangis qu'on rencontre
dimanche prochain et
c'est c'est là aussi dans le tableau de
marche de ce qu'on de ce qu'on s'est
fixé en toute humilité de découvrir la
fédérale 2 de bien y figurer de s'y
maintenir ça c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif majeur on est loin maintenant
déjà loin des des festivités de la
montée de l'année dernière dont on a
beaucoup parlé et on est maintenant au
boulot il découvrir ce gap qui est quand
même relativement relativement nette
entre Fédérale 2 Fédérale 3 et fédéral 2
et on le sent vraiment et notamment
notamment par par l'organisation des
équipes notamment celle qui sont dans la
division depuis quelques temps la
multiplication des entraînements c'est à
dire qu'il y a certaines équipes qui qui
s'entraînent trois voire quatre fois par
semaine alors que côté Versailles on est
encore on est encore sur des rythmes de
fédéral 3 avec deux entraînements par
semaine donc là aussi là aussi on
apprend là aussi on va faire des
réglages sportivement quant à quant au
derby on lui même là aussi comme Dijon
la logique a été respectée c'est à dire
premièrement c'est l'équipe la plus
expérimentée vraiment expérimentée qui
l'a emporté et celle qui était
finalement aussi la plus préparée à aux
côtés dramatique entre guillemets du
derby du derby Vinois
nous après le après ce match là en
analyse froide on s'est dit qu'on avait
fait un long match et que on avait pris
une leçon de Fédérale 2 on a pris une
leçon d'envie une leçon de réalisme le
son de une leçon en mêlée une leçon
d'agressivité au sens rugbytique du
terme et on n'a pas vu le jour on n'a
pas vu le jour on a il y a eu quelques
réactions d'orgueil grâce au bon en 2e
mi-temps
et c'est je dirais même pas que c'est un
match à oublier parce que c'est c'est un
match de fédéral 2 en plus avec une
version derby donc on s'est pris une
jolie porte et un plaisir voilà il y a
plaisir exactement
ils sont très dur à jouer avec un public
un public qui pousse il y a une belle
bataille aussi entre entre les cops où
on était là aussi moins moins fringants
que d'habitude dans la tribune donc la
logique a été respectée sportivement ça
va nous apprendre beaucoup mais là pour
le coup il faut se remettre au boulot
très très vite parce que déjà c'est
risqué se présentent dimanche prochain
on va à Ris et là c'est encore une autre
équipe bien expérimenté en fédéral 2
donc objectif maintien difficile à
atteindre mais on est au boulot une
différence peut-être de moyens aussi je
sais pas après au niveau des moyens si
vous ayez une différence entre plaisir
et Versailles
s'il fallait comparer encore c'est que
sur les Yvelines pour nous c'est une
question
aussi de formation c'est à dire qu'on a
on a dans les dans les catégories jeunes
notamment chez les cadets chez les
juniors la possibilité avec Versailles
de jouer au plus haut niveau au niveau
national du 18 national du 16 national
ce qui n'est pour l'instant pas le cas
pour plaisir donc c'est un espèce de
espèce d'objectif globale de faire jouer
les joueurs formés au club en équipe
première il y en avait il y en avait 6
ou 7 sur la feuille de match en première
lors du derby à plaisir donc moyen non
on a à peu près à peu près les mêmes
moyens et aider par les mêmes
institutions d'une part et des et des
sociétés privées d'autre part
ça se traduit le recrutement ça se
traduit pour nous par une certaine forme
de continuité dans le staff le staff et
les méthodes il y a un plan de jeu à
changer aussi parce que là aussi ça va
plus vite j'en rappelais le match le
match à Orsay on a gagné on a gagné le
match à Orsay sur bizarrement là aussi
sur sur de l'expérience de fédéral 3
c'est-à-dire que là en gros avec des
avec des joueurs plus vieux plus
aguerris côté Versailles et avec une
jeunesse pleine de fou côté Orsay et
c'est sur la gestion du match et des
points à prendre qu'on a réussi petit à
petit à gratter et à passer devant à
Orsay mais ce qu'on a pas su faire par
exemple contre contre Saint-Malo à la
maison et c'est là c'est là la vraie
marche qu'on loupe c'est de perdre ce
match contre Saint-Malo à la maison la
semaine d'après la victoire à Orsay on a
beaucoup parlé de Versailles plaisir
voulait voyez monter cette année ou pas
Jean qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
on parle même d'un projet d'aller en Pro
D2 dans 10 ans
c'est 2e échelon c'est bon
maintenant
l'objectif du club forcement c'est la
montée puisque là quoi 5e saison en
Fédérale 2
maintenant plus on close plus on monte
plus il est difficile de monter et puis
il est difficile d'évoluer au niveau
supérieur et c'est le cas de plaisir ils
ont manqué non pas la montée l'analyse a
manqué la qualification
après la qualification il y a la montée
mais d'abord il faut se qualifier alors
qui joue les phases finales et ensuite
oui pourquoi pas si ça sourit encore une
fois je dis c'est pas on nous parle du
recrutement ou du des moyens c'est pas
ça qui fait la différence c'est
simplement s'habituer s'habituer à ce
niveau là
aux exigences de ce jeu qui qui sont
plus les mêmes que la Fédérale 3 ça va
plus vite ça ça ta plus fort c'est voilà
c'est tout et après leur dire qu'ils
vont monter c'est certainement
l'objectif maintenant qui se qualifie et
là déjà ils ont fait le top 5 c'est
possible c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est un groupe c'est l'équipe de
plaisir est une très belle équipe de
rugby et là pour le coup aguerri
expérimenté le staff également et donc
on a dans la poule là des grosses heures
comme Le Havre et Le Rheu notamment qui
sont qui vont faire qu'aveld cavalier
seul il y a Courbevoie aussi qui qui n'a
pas qui n'a pas encore bien démarré sa
saison mais qui devrait jouer les
premiers rôles mais quand on a cité ces
différentes équipes plaisir peut tout à
fait là pour le coup passer le cap de la
qualification faire au moins les phases
finales il est sans doute un peu tôt
pour pouvoir dire qu'ils sont prêts à
monter en fédéralement en tout cas avec
attention les prouesses de nos versaillé
et de nos plaisirs rois dans ce
championnat de fédéral 2 dans les
prochaines semaines et pourquoi pas un
top 5 en compris pour les plaisirs rois
pourquoi pas pour Versailles on ne sait
jamais on l'espère en tout cas un
maintien est-ce qu'on peut durer on
passe maintenant notre page de départ
[Musique]
dans cette page débat on va parler de
golf l'Open de France était de retour
après trois ans d'absence sur les Green
du Golfe nationale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la dernière
édition c'était en 2019 et après plus
rien à cause du covid-19 fin septembre
avec une météo plutôt clémente 700 4e
édition s'est déroulée devant les yeux
de plusieurs milliers de spectateurs on
les écoute au micro de TV 78
écoutez c'est la première fois que je
viens mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant avec les grands joueurs qui
sont là aujourd'hui je suis sûrement
apprendre des choses c'est très
intéressant on était pas venu depuis
2019 ça commence à nous manquer
Nicolas colsert qui a gagné en 2019 donc
on va venir le voir jouer à nouveau ma
femme est belge alors c'est pour ça donc
je la soutiens encore une belle occasion
de voir voilà les meilleurs golfeurs
c'est vrai que le premier jour c'est
intéressant parce que voilà tout démarre
il y a déjà des il y a déjà des scores
il y a déjà
des résultats mais bon à suivre
et il y a eu du suspense le dimanche 25
septembre plusieurs golfeurs pouvaient
prétendre la victoire parmi eux le
Danois Rasmus hochegard italien Guido
migliosi je sais pas si j'ai bien dit
exactement
ou encore les français Paul Barjon et
Antoine rosener la partie de livinois
était très suivie par ses supporters du
Golfe de la Boulie à Versailles un club
dont il est la tête d'affiche malgré le
soutien indéfectible du public et
quelques fulgurances sur les Green
Antoine Rosner n'est pas dans un bonjour
il termine à la onzième place avec une
carte de 74 ce dimanche 25 septembre on
l'écoute
le jeu a été très bon
toute la semaine franchement il y a rien
à dire là-dessus je suis assez déçu de
ma dernière journée mais
je crois qu'il faut retenir beaucoup de
positif de cette semaine et puis j'ai
vécu voilà quelque chose de d'assez
unique donc voilà beaucoup de beaucoup
de positif à en tirer habite à 25
minutes d'ici la Boulie est à 10 minutes
d'ici donc forcément qui allait avoir
beaucoup de monde donc non c'était
c'était vraiment exceptionnel à vivre et
j'ai hâte de revivre des moments comme
ça
c'est pas facile au bout du suspense si
finalement l'italien Guido miliosi qui
remporte 700 4e édition de l'Open de
France devant le Danois Rasmus Hoche
garde le golfeur de 25 ans égal au
record du parcours avec un magnifique 62
c'est le deuxième golfeur transalpin
remporté le tournoi français
je devrais revenir sur le prochain Open
de France pour défendre son trophée le
rendez-vous reviendra normalement
l'année prochaine sur les grilles du
Golf National de 50 ans en Yvelines la
question sur cette thématique l'Open de
France 2022 est-il une réussite
messieurs oui ou non
oui pour vous Grégory oui pour vous
pierre oui pour vous Jean je ne sais pas
je n'y étais pas
vous inviter sur tous les événements
pour vous et bien sûr évidemment pour
pouvoir en parler alors pourquoi
pourquoi vous
[Musique]
simplement je suis pas spécialiste de
golf
l'Italien qui gagne ben je ne connais
pas plus que ça
notre aiguillement on en parle plus à
revenir on en parle beaucoup plus
souvent donc là en effet ça aurait été
ça aurait été idéal maintenant voilà
c'est vrai que pour moi c'est pas
c'était pas l'événement de l'année
l'idéal pour vous si un Français avait
remporté le tournoi bah évidemment
Chauvin comme je suis je peux vous dire
non
c'est une première depuis 1993 donc ça
c'est quelque chose de très bien niveau
résultat non moi pour moi c'est une
réussite avant de parler de résultat
parce que cette Open de France est tenue
c'est vrai qu'on parlait on avait plus
parler ces dernières saisons sur
splatoon des annulations de l'Open de
France à cause du covid-19 on se
souvient d'une dernière édition un peu
morose il faisait pas très beau au golf
national c'est en 2019
par contre il faut mettre aussi en
avance cette réussite et après niveau
spectateur vous avez parlé de plusieurs
milliers de spectateurs qui sont juste
un petit mythe sur la semaine et c'est
vrai que ça c'est complètement amélioré
sur le weekend justement juste avant de
venir sur cette émission on a à peu près
entre 20 et 21000 spectateurs donc c'est
un petit peu moins bien que les
meilleures saisons de l'Open de France
oui mais on sait que Ben de France on a
parlé aussi souvent en 2019 avait perdu
son sponsor pendant un moment on ne
savait plus si ça allait se dérouler
aussi à 50 ans en Yvelines il y a eu
plusieurs nouveautés un peu négatives
autour de cette Opel de France là il
sait qu'il y en a pu faire une série
d'ailleurs la différence
je pense c'est ce qu'il faut retenir moi
je vais pas m'avancer sur les résultats
sportifs mais en tout cas c'est ce que
j'avais envie de mettre en avant au
moins il s'est tenu sous une météo assez
clémente profitons-en et avec un italien
avec un Italien vainqueur mais je le
rajoute oui donc
par rapport par rapport au spectateur
faut pas faut pas il y a quand même une
baisse de spectateur dans tous les
domaines
voilà donc je pense que les gens ont
quand même n'ont pas repris des études
de sortir et il faut vraiment que les
gens se déplacent aille voir du sport à
y voir du de la de la culture parce que
ça c'est ce sont des domaines qui vont
être qui vont être compliqué en gros de
25 à 30000 personnes sur une compétition
comme l'Open de France en temps normal
je dis bien en temps normal
on va dire 20 21000 cette année 30% de
cas Pierre Chevalier tout dépend de ce
de ce que vous entendez par votre
question sur la réussite c'est est-ce
que c'est une réussite populaire je fais
exprès
oui oui parce que parce que sur une date
comme celle-là qui est une date inédite
en septembre il y avait il y avait quand
même du monde avec une météo Clémence
certes est-ce que c'est une réussite
sportive oui le plateau était le plateau
était quand même pas mal avec un Patrick
ride aussi qui qui sort du chapeau un
peu au dernier moment
un joli vainqueur vraiment un joli
vainqueur des Français qui se qui se
mènent à la parade et à la bataille dès
le délai deux premiers tours ça c'est
moins bien passé sur les trois et quatre
réussite médiatique la mitigé parce que
d'un côté on a un contexte on l'a
rappelé qui est effectivement très
difficile notamment on s'est à peu près
de sources sûr que c'est ça sera la
dernière la dernière la première et la
dernière année de sponsoring du sponsor
titre qui se retire également du
football et du et du nailing de certains
de maillots de certaines équipes
notamment à Lille
à Marseille exactement donc il va
falloir retrouver un partenaire titre et
ça malheureusement l'équipe les équipes
de la Fédération Française de Golf sont
habitués depuis trois quatre ans et
depuis le fiasco à chêné
qui était le sponsor chinois qui était
présent sur l'Open d'action pendant
trois ans deux ans si mes souvenirs sont
bons deux ans et qui a il y avait une
troisième année en option qui n'a pas
été honoré qui est parti à la fin avant
la fin de son contrat et médiatiquement
malgré tout ça a été ça a été diffusé
par par des confrères de chaîne cryptée
on n'a pas forcément les audiences de ce
côté-là mais au moins la communauté des
golfeurs à regarder jusqu'au bout
c'était en plus sur le dernier tour
assez spectaculaire c'est sur les deux
derniers tours d'ailleurs assez
spectaculaire on avait un albatros un
parcours du Golf National qui s'est
vraiment bien bien défendu et voir
notamment le dernier le dernier tour de
midi ça et notamment son dernier coup de
faire au 18 c'est
une superbe publicité pour la beauté du
golf et puis médiatiquement la dernière
chose c'est que on sortait d'un été
extrêmement difficile pour le golf à
cause des polémiques suscités par la
sécheresse et l'utilisation de l'eau
tout à fait raisonnée j'insiste fait par
les clubs de golf qui sont soumis au
même restriction que la plupart des que
la plupart des des parcs publics et en
gros et des particuliers en France ce
qui est pas forcément le cas de certains
sports collectifs et donc on sortait
d'un Nivea d'un été très très morose
là-dessus où on a été un peu attaqué de
toutes parts et encore récemment sur des
des cas de vandalisme sur les parcours
de golf soit pour des questions
environnementales soit pour des
questions de de stéréotypes en gros golf
= sport de riches là s'il y a une chose
c'est que l'Open de France qui est
l'Open de des Français au golf national
c'est que du terme franco-français a pu
attirer un certain nombre de spectateurs
et on l'espère un certain nombre de
nouveaux joueurs et une nouvelle
joueuses autour d'un événement comme
celui-là et d'un sport fabuleux et le
golf genre qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin
peut-être sur cette Open de France ou il
a atteint son plafond de verre est-ce
qu'on peut aller encore plus loin que
cet Open de France est encore un plus
grand rayonnement au niveau français au
niveau international on se souvient de
la chaîne et on en disait précédemment
il y avait Tommy flythwood par exemple
qui était sur les Green du Golf National
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
également Justin Thomas qui est l'un des
meilleurs américains actuellement sur le
circuit il y a quelques années là on n'a
pas assez de tête d'affiches mais est-ce
qu'on peut les ré attirer dans le futur
est-ce que ça peut redevenir un super
événement ce cet Open de France
plusieurs choses c'est difficile de
passer après pierre après le
démonstration
un volley golfique
une autre une autre chose c'est que
contrairement à 2019 ça c'est bon pour
le golf ils ont eu cette année le choix
dans la date et donc ça a pu se dérouler
dans les meilleures conditions ça c'est
une chose ensuite il y a pas de secret
pierre la rappeler le plus gros
partenaire se retire et si on veut avoir
les têtes d'affiche il va falloir aller
chercher
de l'argent le golf alors je dis pas le
golf Le Golf il faut de l'argent parce
que ce sport de riche c'est pas ça du
tout le tennis c'est la même cas de
figure la Formule 1 enfin tout tous les
sports qui qui amènent qui amène un
petit peu de de d'argent qui draine un
petit peu d'argent derrière toutes ces
compétitions et il y a pas de secret si
on veut des têtes d'affiche mais
on n'attire pas les mouches avec du miel
redorer le blason de cette compétition
de l'Open de France mais il faudra aller
chercher un ou plusieurs partenaires
mais au niveau qu'on puisse et Pascal
Griso veut travailler en ce sens-là
mais on ne pourra pas on ne pourra pas
faire venir des grands joueurs avec avec
des épluchures il faudra se décider vite
puisque prochaine édition l'année
prochaine année de la Ryder Cup et sur
ce créneau de date on est sur le même
créneau aussi de date de la radio de la
Ryder Cup pardon c'est en Italie
on marque aussi monnaie golfeur voilà
donc
c'est pas on avait été surpris qu'on
avait c'est pas le même on avait été
chauffé mais ils ont pas forcément choix
dans la date l'année prochaine donc il
faudra il faudra aussi qui se qui se
place sur ce dossier
dans notre prochaine thématique nous
allons parler je vous vois sourire enfin
par le sport
je vous vois sourire donc c'est votre
spécialité les championnats du monde
sont programmés du 12 au 16 octobre au
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce sera la
deuxième fois que la structure
accueillera la compétition après 2015
restez là Monsieur restez là je vous
vois je vois dépité mais vous inquiétez
pas ça va bien se passer alors la
sélection tricolore a été présentée ce
mardi 4 octobre on retrouve dans cette
équipe de France des têtes d'affiches
comme Sébastien Vigier ryanella ou
Mathilde de gros on les écoute justement
cette on écoute justement ces sportif au
micro de TV 78
ça va être quelque chose de top donc je
me dis voilà j'ai hâte on a encore
quelques jours pour pour peaufiner les
derniers réglages et après bah se lancer
et tout donner devant le public la
famille les amis moi j'ai fait les
Europe ici en 2016 mais il y avait pas
les tribunes pleines donc ça sera un
premier premier championnat domicile
avec 6000 personnes derrière moi
derrière nous même pour l'équipe de
France
alors il n'y a pas d'objectif en termes
de médaille en tout cas pas d'objectif
annoncés mais cette équipe de France
semble bien armée on écoute les
responsables on est dans des disciplines
qu'on maîtrise où on a des favoris de de
certaines épreuves et surtout on va
courir à domicile encouragé par par on
l'espère un public nombreux et
communicante prendre plaisir à prendre
plaisir c'est quelque chose d'important
mais il faut pas se prendre la tête ou
se mettre plus de pression le gros du
travail comme je leur ai dit a été fait
dans l'année donc il y a une bonne
préparation et après ben faudra faudra
en découdre le jour J
en 2015 la France avait remporté 5
médailles d'or en or et deux en bronze
la France avait terminé première du
tableau des médailles la question sur ce
thème est-ce que c'est une répétition
décisive au niveau sportif et au niveau
des infrastructures en vue des Jeux
Olympiques
est-ce que c'est décisif ce rendez-vous
c'est pour les enfants
au niveau sportif pour les athlètes et
au niveau de l'infrastructure du
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines au niveau
sportif non au niveau des
infrastructures oui d'accord d'accord
je sais qui est ça le démange depuis
tout à l'heure non mais sur les
infrastructures on sait que ça va
arriver très vite cette échéance
olympique on est désormais à moins de
deux ans de ces JO il y a beaucoup
d'épreuves dans les Yvelines ce
vélodrome national sera un peu la figure
de proue de ses épreuves dans les
Yvelines et forcément des événements
tests comme des mondiaux de cyclisme sur
piste qui vont attiré à peu près 25000
spectateurs sur sur cet échange sur cinq
jours il y en aura pas des masses d'ici
2024 donc forcément que ce genre
d'événement il faut en profiter pour les
organisateurs pour répéter peut-être
régler les derniers détails mais il y en
aura voilà il y aura pas énormément
d'événements d'ici 2024 donc c'est très
important de pouvoir tester les
infrastructures le c'est un bon test
pour le vélo de Drôme vienne du Jarrier
oui oui et je suis étonné que vous
annonciez 25000 personnes présentes a
priori ça guichet fermée
parce que moi j'ai regardé il y a encore
des places pour vendredi donc je
la Fédération Française en tout cas à
communiquer là-dessus hier ce
mardi 4 octobre
mes enfants seront peut-être pas
présents alors parce que j'attendais le
dernier moment ah non non ça fait déjà
trois semaines que je regarde pour pour
justement y aller j'étais pas stressé
rien du tout donc j'ai regardé il y a
deux jours donc peut-être réserver Yann
non non je pense que je pense que c'est
la fête des qui qui joue le qui joue le
bluff mais c'est pas grave
oui c'est une c'est important parce que
oui 5000 personnes qui se dépassent au
Vélodrome on sait très bien qu'il y a
beaucoup de problématiques pas de
parking pas de enfin peu de parking pas
de donc oui c'est une vraie répétition
pour faut savoir comment est-ce qu'on va
déplacer tout le monde ça c'était très
bien passé pour cet événement
depuis 2015 beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous
les ponts et beaucoup d'événements ce
sont déroulés dans des conditions pas
toujours très glorieuses voilà
Jean qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
parce que ça vous médaille en or et deux
en bourse en 2015
pour moi ça peut être une année
prolifique en termes de médaille il y a
un gros souci dans le cyclisme sur piste
avec les Hollandais qui sont dominateurs
qui sont dominateurs sur le sprint mais
par contre sur toutes les autres
épreuves la France est une très très
grosse nation aujourd'hui on a de Novak
Grondin qui est qui est énorme sur les
courses de fonds
de la route je pense que ils ont ils ont
juste peur ils ont juste de peur
d’annoncer un chiffre qui serait qui
serait
en France
aussi lors de la conférence de presse
d'habitude il n'y a pas autant de
journalistes présents là il y avait
énormément de journalistes qui étaient
présents pour les Jeux Olympiques et
c'est déjà une première étape
c'est l'échauffement c'est la
préparation il faut dire aussi que
l'équipe de France sort de de gros
championnats d'Europe il y a eu 6
médailles en or obtenu sur ces
championnats d'Europe à Munich cet été
je mets un gros bémol sur champion
on a brillé tu vois moi je le dis
j'aurais dit ne tenez peut-être pas
compte des résultats qu'on a eu au
championnat d'Europe il faut pas espérer
parce qu'on a eu énormément de ménage tu
vois mais mais au moins communiquer
honnêtement ça me dérange sauf que sauf
que moi je pense qu'avec la
surmotivation qui va y avoir et là qui
qui était déjà le cas en 2015 euh
François Pervis gagne deux titres à
cette époque là il était loin d'être le
meilleur le meilleur mondial mais ils
ont couru en France ils gagnent la
vitesse par équipe enfin voilà c'était
juste énorme et en effet c'était des
choses qui n'était pas attendu mais ils
sont ici ils sont il y a une il y a il y
a
une motivation supplémentaire et je
pense qu'elle va être galvanisante aussi
pour nos pour nos coureurs aujourd'hui
donc moi j'ai pas peur de me dire que il
peut faire autant de titres que qu'au
championnat d'Europe mais c'est juste
c'est parce que difficile de le penser
et de le ré et de l'imaginer donc je
peux comprendre qu'il se soit dit on
annonce rien et on va faire une belle
surprise derrière et je pense que de
toute façon s'il n'y a pas de s'il y a
pas de résultats ils seront allumés de
toute façon parce que justement les
championnats d'Europe ont été bon ils
doivent confirmer sur le championnat du
monde
en tout cas Yann on débrief fresnant
deux semaines après les championnats du
monde on verra si vous avez raison
la semaine
et on va pouvoir en parler et avec grand
plaisir
malheureusement la fin de cette émission
va terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation du champion de MMA Connor
McGregor le doute s'efface par l'action
si tu ne travailles pas le doute
apparaît si tu vois c'est la fin de
cette émission voilà je le disais si tu
travailles le doute disparaît je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]